this
is the largest protest in poland since
the fall of communism more than 30 years
ago
hundreds of thousands are protesting in
cities across the country
because the party in power here is on
the verge of eliminating a woman's right
to an abortion
[Music]
at the heart of these protests are young
women those who are the most threatened
by the new ruling
but there are many many others too
and that's because these protesters
aren't just concerned about the
future of abortion rights in poland
they're worried
about the future of the country itself
in the late 1980s poland got rid of its
decades-long communist regime
soon it became a thriving democracy with
a strong catholic identity
it also passed one of the strictest laws
on abortion
in all of europe under the law
women were only allowed to have an
abortion under three circumstances
if the pregnancy was a threat to the
health of the mother
if it was the result of incest or rape
or if the fetus had severe and
irreversible abnormalities
the law has remained this way for nearly
30 years
and today it makes poland an outlier in
europe
where virtually every other country
allows abortions
under a broad range of circumstances but
some in poland
thought those strict laws were still not
enough
in 2015 poland elected the right-wing
party law and justice into power
shortly after the party leader said even
pregnancies when a child is sure to die
should end with the mother giving birth
so the child can be baptized
buried and have a name very close to the
totalitarian way of thinking as far as
women
health women's rights and women
personhood is concerned
in 2016 the party backed legislation to
eliminate
all three legal paths to abortion the
legislation
proposed imprisoning women seeking
abortions and
doctors who performed them for up to
five years
they would even investigate miscarriages
this is something
that is incredible you know really turns
us back to the middle ages so the
limitation of the human rights
went far too far thousands of women took
to the streets
pushing back against the law in what
were called the black
protests in the face of this opposition
the legislation was withdrawn
poland would still have one of the
strictest abortion laws in europe
but not a total ban
but instead of giving up on the abortion
ban law and justice
started dismantling the country's
ability to oppose one
in poland's democracy some legislation
passed by parliament is sent to the
constitutional tribunal
to ensure it's consistent with the
country's constitution this court has
15 judges and it serves as the main
check on the ruling party
it's supposed to function as an
independent branch of the government
but upon taking power law and justice
started to erode that independence
they refused to swear in several judges
who had been appointed by the previous
government
and replaced them with judges who would
be loyal to them
including the tribunal president who has
the ability to determine which judges
hear
what cases and of the judges they have
appointed
legally many are actually fellow
politicians
further compromising the independence of
the court
this has created a tribunal in which 14
of 15 judges
are aligned with the ruling party and
the legitimacy of several of them
is widely disputed both in poland and
internationally this version of the
court has
never decided a case against the ruling
party
the fact that this constitutional
tribunal is
acting on behalf of the political party
it's just
opposite of what constitutional
tribunals should do
it was under these circumstances that
law and justice
sought a new ruling from the
constitutional tribunal on the country's
abortion laws
that would eliminate one of the three
bases for legal abortion
severe fetal abnormalities and while it
might seem like that would only prevent
some abortions
fetal abnormalities are the reason for
98
of abortions in poland in other words
without technically banning abortions
the change would make them virtually
impossible nearly 80 percent of polls
disagreed with this change
but on october 22nd the constitutional
tribunal ruled in its favor
that the overwhelming majority of
abortions in poland
were unconstitutional
the ruling brought poles back into the
streets and in
much bigger numbers than in 2016. these
protests are
really different to what we've seen for
the last four years because
there are thousands and thousands of
young people attending these protests
organizing these protests
and also these are the most grassroots
independent protests that we've ever had
[Music]
in the face of protests the government
has delayed taking the steps that would
make the ruling
official as of this video it's unclear
when
or if they will but
these protests are as much about how
this ruling came together as they are
about the ruling itself
it started with abortion now we fight
for freedom for everything
for the rule of law outside of poland
the world has noticed
international organizations have stopped
considering it a full democracy
and the changes to its legal system have
put poland's european union membership
at risk
[Music]
thirty years ago poland enthusiastically
embraced democracy
today its ruling party is trying to rig
the country's democratic institutions in
its favor
and it's the people who are fighting to
protect them
[Music]
despite of the fact that this government
is responsible
for destroying all the democratic tools
that we have in our constitution
you still have the nation the citizens
in this country who carry on the
democratic values
[Music]
we
[Music]
you